The site director was boiling over with rage.
This was supposed to be a safe facility - one
where low-threat and well-behaved humanoid
SCPs were kept with minimal security.
But if this kept up, these containment breaches
could easily bring the attention of SCP brass
- the last thing any of them wanted.
“Can anyone explain?”
The director demanded, pausing to calm himself.
“Why do we have so much trouble keeping
this subject safely contained?
This is not the first containment breach!”
The security team looked at each other nervously.
“Well, sir, nothing is ever certain.
We’ve made sure everyone has the proper
security protocols in place, but SCPs are
always unpredictable - “
“It’s a little girl!”
The director slammed his fist on the table.
“Look at these security protocols!
Stuffed animals!
Playtime!
This girl is obviously not a threat - so what’s
going on here?”
The security heads exchanged another nervous
glance.
“You’re right, sir - the specimen isn’t
the security threat here.
It’s the researchers.”
SCP-2118 was secured by the Foundation with
both minimal apprehension as well as a smaller
team of personnel, after multiple reports
of her unique abilities were identified.
She appears to be a normal child under ten
years of age, with orange hair and a long
scar on her right cheek.
2118 claims that her scar is the result of
an assault by a stranger on the street.
She communicated this via sign language, as
she rarely, if ever, vocalizes words.
She is, however, capable of speech, and THAT
is where her unique abilities lie.
SCP-2118 does not speak in her own voice,
and it is still unclear as to whether or not
she even possesses one.
Her speech only activates in one situation
- in the presence of a parent who has lost
a child under the age of eighteen to death.
Under this circumstance only will SCP-2118
begin to speak, but rarely in the same voice
twice.
Because SCP-2118’s voice isn’t her own.
Automatically and involuntarily, 2118’s
voice pattern becomes that of the child who
died, speaking to their “parent” in a
way that reflects both the age and gender
of their deceased offspring.
The voice that is heard is referred to as
SCP-2118-01 by the Foundation.
SCP-2118 is aware of her speech and vocal
patterns as well as the psychological distress
they cause the parent, as she will use sign
language to apologize even as SCP-2118-01
continues speaking.
But this isn’t the only disturbing part
of her abilities.
While at first the conversation can be generic,
most times the words and sounds coming out
of SCP-2118’s mouth reflect the final words
and sounds of the dead child.
This not only includes disturbing pleas for
help, but can reflect the actual sounds of
dying - mimicking the agony of drowning, disease,
or death by fire.
SCP-2118 wasn’t necessarily a danger to
anyone - however, her presence could absolutely
pose a dangerous temptation.
The director finished looking over the files.
It seemed like everything had been handled
smoothly and by the books when SCP-2118 was
initially brought in - but along the way,
something had gone wrong.
The case was being handled by one of his most
trusted researchers, Dr. Wu.
As it became clear that SCP-2118 didn’t
talk normally, translators who could interpret
ASL were brought in for the first interview.
Dr. Wu and site psychologist Dr. Lavoie welcomed
the strange little girl to the SCP facility.
This interview provided the Foundation its
first intel on where SCP-2118 had come from.
At first, the little girl was alarmed.
She didn’t like being referred to by her
SCP number and insisted on her original name.
She understood that she was in a science lab
of some sort, but thought she had been brought
there because she had done something wrong.
She referenced a woman attacking her with
her purse at one point, and also claimed that
any time she spoke, people would get angry.
But then she revealed something more disturbing.
She knew why people got angry when she spoke
- from her mother.
She had lived with her parent, and at some
point her mother had lost a baby - after the
traumatic incident, every time 2118 spoke,
she spoke in the voice of the sibling she
had lost.
This caused her mother to become angry, and
out of shame, provoked 2118 to glue her own
mouth shut to prevent it from happening.
Due to the glue being a little too strong,
it resulted in a visit to the hospital - something
she thought might happen again at the facility.
But no one was sure if she was scared of it
- or hoping for it.
More than anything, the little girl just didn’t
want people to stop talking to her.
The Foundation had a long way to go in understanding
SCP-2118’s abilities.
Dr. Lavoie and Dr. Wu both seemed to have
a good rapport with the girl, and they were
kept in charge of her case.
Neither one had children, and could converse
with her without difficulty as long as a translator
was present.
But to test her abilities, there would have
to be an experiment conducted involving someone
who could actually activate them.
And it just so happened that D-3498, a volatile
conscript working at the facility, had been
convicted of the murder of his wife - and
his daughter.
BUT the experiment would prove to be more
than anyone was bargaining for.
As soon as D-3498 was brought in, SCP-2118
became silent.
After about thirty seconds, she signed an
apology for what was about to happen - and
then began screaming at the top of her lungs.
She cried out for her father in an anguished
voice, all the while signing apologies.
D-3498 became increasingly angry, demanding
to know what was going on.
He struggled against his restraints and howled
obscenities as he listened to his daughter’s
strangled pleas for help, begging, and ultimately,
her death rattle.
Two agents, recorded as Agent M and Agent
C, were brought in to end the experiment and
remove D-3498.
And that’s when things took an unexpected
turn.
While Agent C removed the D-class, Agent M
seemed oddly fixated on SCP-2118.
The reason why became clear as soon as SCP-2118
opened her mouth.
“Mama?”
The voice had changed completely, to that
of a young boy several years older than the
D-class’ daughter.
The boy seemed distraught, complaining of
being cold and scared and wanting to know
where his mother was.
Agent M seemed frozen in place, and didn’t
answer Dr. Lavoie’s questions.
The experiment was quickly terminated, SCP-2118
was removed to her living quarters, and Agent
M was removed from duty with the case of a
possible missing or murdered child referred
to police authorities.
SCP-2118 may have cracked a cold case - but
she also posed a dangerous temptation.
It wouldn’t be long before the case had
its first security breach.
Researcher Anselman conducted an interview
with SCP-2118 - despite not being assigned
to the case.
Anselman didn’t have access to the SCP’s
living quarters, so he watched SCP-2118 sleep
and then communicated with her through the
glass.
The events were captured on facility cameras,
and showed that SCP-2118 was agitated from
the start, knowing that Anselman was not supposed
to be there.
And Anselman had an ulterior motive.
As soon as their conversation began, SCP-2118,
using sign language, asked Anselman why she
was being made to do this.
Soon afterwards, SCP-2118 started speaking
in the voice of a prepubescent boy that Anselman
called Dewey - and who referred to Anselman
as dad.
The boy was clearly agitated - as was SCP-2118
- and asked his father what happens after
they die.
Anselman became upset - wanting to hear answers
from his lost son, not questions.
SCP-2118 tried to warn him off, letting Anselman
know that he couldn’t actually communicate
with his son through her and she couldn’t
help him.
But Anselman persisted, watching as SCP-2118
imitated the sounds of a boy gasping and taking
his last breaths - consistent with a death
from illness, rather than accident or violence.
All the while, SCP-2118 just watched sadly.
The security breach was soon discovered, and
Researcher Anselman was removed and reprimanded
for unauthorized testing with SCP-2118.
But thanks to the researcher’s breach, the
Foundation did gain new knowledge of SCP-2118’s
abilities - namely that she couldn’t actually
channel the spirits of the dead.
She was a mimic who could involuntarily duplicate
their last moments, but couldn’t provide
any new information from them or answer questions
that they didn’t know in life - and she
didn’t have any special knowledge of what
came after life.
But her abilities did have one unique potential.
By channeling the last moments of a deceased
child, she could possibly provide answers
for authorities as to their whereabouts or
their killer - as she had unexpectedly done
with Agent M. The problem was, this process
seemed to be deeply disturbing for SCP-2118,
who showed great emotional distress when forced
to channel a dead child and consistently apologized
for the effect on the parents.
Which left the Foundation in an ethical dilemma.
“Sir?
How do you want to proceed?”
The site director looked over the files.
Clearly this couldn’t continue and something
needed to be done - but none of the security
breaches or other incidents had been SCP-2118’s
fault.
She had been cooperative, despite the trauma
these tests seemed to cause her.
To keep her safe, and to preserve her use
to the Foundation, things would need to change.
“We could transfer SCP-2118 to a more secure
facility - but I’m not going to do that.
Keep her cell furnished with all the things
a girl her age would want - it says here she
likes orcas and elephants.
Take her outside to an enclosed play area
once a day, for about an hour - no more.
But above all, make sure she’s always with
an attendant who can converse in sign language.
She’s not to be around anyone who has had
children unless it’s necessary for testing.
Convey these new parameters to Drs. Wu and
Lavoie, and make sure to increase security
around her quarters - as much for her protection
as anything else.”
The security team scurried off, happy to have
avoided the director’s wrath.
The director turned back to the files.
Yes, he had solved the problem for now, but
he would have to keep a closer eye on the
facility as a whole.
The SCP foundation did close background checks
on its staff and on D-class personnel before
bringing them in, but SCPs were unpredictable
- and you never knew what could make someone
a security risk.
How many employees working at the facility
had lost a child?
How many, like the disgraced Researcher Anselman,
would do anything to hear their child’s
voice again - even if it was in the middle
of death?
For another story of a seemingly harmless
child with unusual effects, check out “SCP-053
- Young Girl”, or watch this video instead.